while we were on vacation Fox News host
Tucker Carlson made the baseless claim
at least as far as he's presented
evidence that the NSA the National
Security Agency had been spying on him
and then the story disappeared for a
little bit until yesterday Tucker
appeared on the Fox Business program
mornings with Maria hosted by the
notorious Trump brown noser Maria
Bartiromo Tucker is now saying that he
recently learned that it will soon come
out that not only has the NSA been
spying on him but the NSA leaked the
contents of his emails to journalists in
an effort to discredit him in relation
to I guess seeking an interview with
Vladimir Putin now he says it's not a
figment of his imagination that it is
very very real so let's look at this
interview that he had with Maria
Bartiromo and
um these are very serious allegations so
let's listen to it the NS say spying
Tucker Carlson tonight host Tucker
carlston said last week on his program
that he has information from a
whistleblower showing that the NSA is
spying on him and planning to leak
sensitive Communications to get his show
canceled Tucker joins us right now
Tucker it's great to have you this
morning thank you so much for being here
oh yeah you are the only people I get up
for Maria it's an honor to be here yeah
it's you don't go on TV politely to say
the government is spying on me because
you sound like a crazy person and of
course she would never say that unless
you knew that it was true and I did know
that it was true almost accidentally I
was in Washington for a funeral last
week and ran into someone I know Wells
that I have a message for you and then
proceeded to repeat back to me details
from emails and texts that I sent and
had told no one else about so it was
verified and this person said look the
you know now what's important to
understand here is this is Tucker's
assertion and we have to be able to
distinguish between
if what Tucker is saying is true then
XYZ versus simply Tucker is making this
assertion and as yet has not presented
any evidence for it now the first thing
to understand is just because we would
be skeptical of this claim because
there's not yet been evidence presented
doesn't mean that we think the NSA is
great or always acts appropriately and
this is a really important thing in the
Trump era often when if you're on the
left and you say hey you know what
there's really no reason to doubt the
FBI when the FBI said X or there's
really no reason to doubt the CIA when
the CIA said why sometimes right-wingers
and even sometimes leftists will say Oh
what now you love the CIA
which did all this bad stuff globally
for decades no no we're just looking at
these claims the NSA does spy on people
that's what they do
the NSA could leak stuff but Tucker has
not yet presented evidence and maybe he
will so we're not laughing this off if
the NSA is spying on Tucker and leaking
his emails I want to know but as you
will see here he's not yet presenting
any evidence let's look at a little bit
more of this it has this and that was
proven by the person repeating back the
contents of the email
and is going to use it against you now
to be totally blunt with you I would
never have said this in public if it was
something I felt was wrong or illegal or
immoral they don't actually have
anything on me but they do have my
emails so I knew they were spying on me
and and again to be totally bunt with
you as a defensive move I thought I
better say this out loud because I have
no I have no other way to defend myself
I'm just an American citizen I don't
have
you know any position of official
Authority but I do have a megaphone
right he does have a megaphone it's a
little bit I mean listen when you have
one of the top rated shows on one of the
three major cable networks to say you're
no one special essentially is what he's
saying uh it's not exactly
representative of the spirit of Tucker's
privileged position but let's not harp
on that too much say this out loud and I
did
and the NSA didn't deny it then
yesterday okay I learned that and this
is going to come out soon that the NSA
delete the contents of my email to
journalists in an effort to discredit me
I know because I got a call from one of
them saying Oh this is what your email
was about so it is not in any way a
figment of my imagination it's confirmed
it's true they're not allowed to spy on
American citizens they are okay so
there's a there's a ton of stuff there
now Tucker says the NSA didn't deny
a part of this let's look at what the
NSA actually said because
I I think it's it's important to
actually see the wording the NSA put out
a statement saying on June 28 2021
Tucker Carlson alleged that the NSA has
been quote monitoring our Communications
and is planning to leak them in an
attempt to take this show off the air
this allegation is untrue
Tucker Carlson has never been an
intelligence Target of the agency and
the NSA has never had any plans to try
to take his program off the air
NSA has a foreign intelligence Mission
we target foreign powers to generate
insights on foreign activities that
could harm the United States with
limited exceptions like an emergency the
NSA may not Target a U.S citizen without
a court order that explicitly authorizes
the targeting now what what Tucker is
focusing in on there is that the NSA
doesn't deny reading his emails now it
is possible
um and this you know with all of the
Trump people American Trump people that
were in contact with Russians when the
Russians were being surveilled which we
could say we don't like that this is
what the NSA does but the NSA has a
foreign intelligence Mission when the
NSA was monitoring Russians when Trump
people communicated with the Russians
incidentally they observed the
communications of the Americans who were
in touch with the Russians right so
Tucker then last night talked in more
detail about what this is all about
what if you listen to it it could
explain some of this okay and then we'll
talk about whether it's okay I guess God
we're happy to report that late this
spring I contacted a couple of people I
thought could help get us an interview
with Russian President Vladimir Putin
yeah I told nobody I was doing this
other than my executive producer Justin
Wells I wasn't embarrassed about trying
to interview Putin he's obviously
newsworthy she's an American citizen I
can interview anyone I want I don't plan
to but still in this case I decided to
keep it quiet I figured that any kind of
publicity would rattle the Russians and
make the interview less likely to happen
but the Biden Administration found out
anyway by reading my emails I learned
from a whistleblower the NSA planned to
leak the contents so first of all it's
important that when he when you say the
Biden Administration
to you know that that's questionable
language for this if you understand how
you know Trump was constantly
criticizing the FBI for things it did
during his administration if you apply
this logic it that was the Trump
Administration right if any action taken
by FBI CIA or NSA
uh during a presidency is that
presidency that Administration doing it
then it was the Trump Administration
that did all the things that Trump
criticized the FBI for I think that's
pretty dubious emails to Media Outlets
why would they do that well the point of
course was to paint me as a disloyal
American a Russian operative been called
that before a stooge of the Kremlin a
traitor doing the bidding of a foreign
adversary and of course I mean hardly
the only person who's been accused of
those things so okay so so let's let's
talk about what's going on here now that
we have the full picture
um many of these allegations are just
unproven okay the the leaks by the NSA
to journalists all it's if there's
evidence of that then I want to see it I
want to know what the NSA is doing I
don't think the NSA is uniquely good or
bad uh American intelligence agencies
sometimes do good things sometimes they
do bad things sometimes it's not easy to
call something good or bad uh if Tucker
Carlson was in touch with uh people he
may or may not have known are Kremlin
agents Uh Russian intelligence who who
knows who Tucker was in touch with in
order to try to get an interview with
Vladimir Putin if those people were
being monitored by the NSA
then certainly by being in touch with
them Tucker's Communications would it
would have ended up monitored by the NSA
this is not hugely shocking or
controversial if you're talking to
someone who's under surveillance like a
foreign intelligence Target then by
talking to them you're going to be
surveilled we can debate that's good or
bad but it's not shocking so number one
is Tucker going to present proof we'll
have to wait and see number two where
was Tucker on this stuff for years when
uh uh uh it was happening already now
all of a sudden that he believes or is
at least claiming it's happening to him
it's his number one issue so there's a
lot of stuff here to clear up but I want
to be really clear
if what Tucker is saying is true I want
to know about it but it wouldn't be
shocking that if Tucker is talking to
people foreign agents being surveilled
by American intelligence it would be
logical that his side of the
communication is also going to be
subject to that surveillance not
defending it but it's exactly what you
would expect let me know your thoughts
we'll have more of this on our Instagram
which you can find at davidpackman show
one of our sponsors today is blue blocks
blue blocks glasses filter out the blue
light coming from your computer screen
your phone your TV which can be really
helpful because blue light from screens
can cause eye strain headaches even
trouble sleeping at night these are my
blue blocks glasses they've been a big
help I'm no longer feeling that eye
strain I'm falling asleep easier at
night because blue light suppresses the
sleep hormone melatonin so the blue
blocks glasses just make it easier to
fall asleep at night for many people and
blue blocks is the company you can trust
because their glasses were developed in
actual Optics labs in line with the
peer-reviewed academic literature they
have 40 different frames to choose from
there's even a prescription version they
also have readers there's really
something for everybody go to
blueblocks.com Pacman and you'll get 20
off everything in their store plus free
shipping worldwide on orders over 115
dollars oh